[Musique]
oui
bonjour didier dont je suis directeur et
chef de cuisine des autres roches du
relais châteaux les hautes roches à côté
tout un rouge qu'au rebond plus
précisément la particularité du site
c'est que ces troubles auditifs ça
signifie que c'est dans le rouge cédant
la pierre mais ça remonte à quand même
aux environs 700 800 après jésus-christ
a donc c'était un lieu où ont vécu ici
des moines il ya une chose qui m'a
marqué c'est la cuisine de mon père mon
père qui était pas du tout un cuisinier
de métier mais par quoi inquiéter un
type qui faisait super bien la cuisine
j'ai un souvenir de rognons de rognons
au madère s'il ya un clin d'oeil que je
veux faire c'est celui là c'est à mon
coeur alors vous réalisez la note
reflète de racan avec avec sa cuisse
farci aux serments et poires tapées on
va donc avoir besoin de notre fameuse
poule f de raconte un petit produit
local on va avoir besoin aussi du ca
demeures des fruits taper un peu
d'épinards pour la farce des noix la
chapelure une fois d'échalotes un peu de
vin devrait on est dans le pays
et puis la crème pour déglacer avec le
vin de vouvray dans la cocotte donc les
deux cuisses que je vais désossé
il va falloir que je confectionne la
face donc là mes épinards blanchi un
petit peu de sainte-maure ça va amener
du moins deux sur les épinards
[Musique]
écrasés en quelque sorte le mélange pour
en faire quelque chose d'un peu plus
compact
[Musique]
là
c
[Musique]
aum
oh
mais là
et là on va mettre la crème ailleurs en
phase de finition de la sauce puis là on
va passer au dressage
[Musique]
bon appétit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui